[موسيقى] بيروت تعيد بناء مرة أخرى الزلازل والحروب دمرت هذه المدينة وضربتها على مر القرون ، ثم في الصيف الماضي تمكن هؤلاء الناس دائمًا بطريقة أو بأخرى من النهوض من الرماد الذين فقدوا أكثر من 200 شخص في انفجار لحم الخنزير في بيروت ، ومع ذلك فقد ذهبوا إلى الأبد خمسة عشر- توفي الياس حوري ، البالغ من العمر عام ، متأثراً بجراحه بعد أسبوعين من الانفجار ، ليس لدينا مستقبل بعد مقتل هذا الشاب ، أخبرني عمه جورج أننا نحاول إقناع أخته بالانتقال إلى كندا للبقاء مع خالتها وعدم البقاء هنا. لأن هذا البلد ليس له مستقبل عام 2020 بدأ بمزيد من الاحتجاجات المناهضة للحكومة والاشتباكات المستمرة منذ الانتفاضة التي اندلعت في أكتوبر 2019. ومنذ ذلك الحين انهار الاقتصاد ، وفقدت العملة 70 في المائة من قيمتها ، وتقول الأمم المتحدة إن 55 من السكان يعيش الآن تحت خط الفقر الذي تفاقم بسبب جائحة الفيروس التاجي بعد كل هذا لبنان دائمًا يبدو أن البناء الهش ينهار ، نعم ج  يحاول آرل سركيس إصلاح
مبنى عائلته ،
لكن مع زوجته الحامل
والسياسيون اللبنانيون الغارقون في خلافات قديمة
غير قادرين على تشكيل حكومة ، فإنهم
ينظرون إلى المخرج
الذي نخطط لمغادرة
البلاد لطفلي ، نعم
لا يوجد مستقبل  لأنه لا يزال
لدينا نفس الأشخاص الذين تحكمهم حكومتنا
ماريانا ويبي ، شاركت في تأسيس مجموعة بابل
شبيك
العربية للباب والنافذة لمساعدة
الناس على إصلاح منازلهم بعد
الانفجار ،
نحتاج إلى التفكير فيما يتعين علينا
القيام به لإنقاذ كل ما هو موجود  بقي من
مدينتنا نبضات قلبنا أنت تعلم أن
هذا هو قلب البلد الذي
تم
تدميره ، فقد اختفى الآلاف الذين احتجوا في
قلب بيروت.
التغيير الحقيقي سيأتي
يقول أستاذ جامعي وناشط
منى خصومه
لكن يجب عليهم أولاً أن يداويوا فلا
شك  أن
الانفجار دمر الأمل وطموح
وطاقة العديد من الأشخاص والتي
كانت لحظة عنيفة بشكل لا يصدق
حتى نتمكن من إنكار أن هذا حدث  بينيد
وأن الناس سوف يستغرقون وقتًا
لاستعادة الندبات ولكن لن تختفي
بن ويدمان